ده ايه بفرجار
[موسيقى]
يطرح نفسه كزعيم لمدرسه رونالد ريجن
التقليديه مسلحا بمبادئ الحزب المحافظه
استراتيجيته تعتمد على مهاجمه الرئيس
بايدن لكن نائب الرئيس السابق مايك بينس
لا يذكر اسم الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في اعلانه الترشح لانتخابات الرئاسه ويطلق
حملته الانتخابيه من ولايه ايوا التي
تعتبر نقطه الانطلاق نحو البيت الابيض
هي المكان الذي شكلنا فيه قيادتنا المحافظ
ايا وهي الولايه التي تحدد معالم مرشح
الانتخابات ويجب ان اخبركم انه خلال
العامين الماضيين امضينا انا وكارين
الكثير من الوقت في التفكير والصلاه بشان
كل ما يواجه بلدنا وما يمكننا فعله للخدمه
نائب الرئيس السابق ينضم رسميا الى عدد من
المرشحين الذين يتحدون رئيسهم السابق مثل
نيكي هيلي حاكمه ولايه السابقه وكريس
كريستي حاكم ولايه نيوجيرسي السابق
والسنهور الجمهوريه الوحيد الذي ينحدر من
اصول افريقيه لكن التحدي الحقيقي للرئيس
ترامب ياتي من حاكم فلوريدا
انا متاكد من ان ترامب يفكر كالتالي انا
من صنع مايك بينس فقد كان حاكم ولايتي
للمره الثانيه ولم يسمع به احد من قبل لكن
اي شكر حصلت عليه منه لم يقبل بانس بتجاوز
دستور الولايات المتحده في السادس من
يناير والان هذا الرجل يترشح للانتخابات
ضدي
جميع المرشحين يجربون حدودهم ويعرضون
اجدتهم المحافظه اجتماعيا وماليا ويهاجمون
الرئيس بايدن ويعتبرونه فاشلا في انقاذ
الاقتصاد وترد القيم الاجتماعيه
لكن البعض يرى ان العدد المتزايد للمرشحين
سيعطي افضليه للرئيس ترامب حيث ستتوزع
الاصوات بينهم ويصبح هو الفائز والبعض
الاخر يرى ان مشاكل ترامب القانونيه قد
تمنعه من الترشح في النهايه
حتى الان
حاكم ولايه نيوجيرسي السابق هو الوحيد بين
المرشحين الجمهوريين الذي بدا يهاجم
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بشكل جديد هذا
قد لا يؤثر في القاعده المخلصه الشعبيه
التي بقت وفيه للرئيس ترامب لكنه قد يؤثر
في النهايه في شريحه معينه من الحزب
الجمهوري التي لا تريد ان يكون ترامب هو
مرشح للحزب الجمهوري نادي البلبيسي
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات